Oh
it seems to me that the most obvious
thing that we can do to test this idea
that life does form readily an
earth-like conditions an idea
incidentally that Christian de Duve
who's a famous biologist is called the
cosmic imperative it's sort of wonderful
phrase so how do we test the cosmic
imperative what we wanted to find a
second sample of life and what Chris
McKay at NASA Ames calls life 2.0 we've
got like 1.0 here it is what we want is
another sample of life which is not on
our tree of life at all all life that
we've studied so far on earth belongs to
the same tree we share genes for example
with mushrooms and oak trees and and
fish and bacteria that live in volcanic
vents and so on that it's all the same
life descended from a common origin what
we want is a secondary of life we want
alien life alien not necessarily in the
sense of having come from space they
might have done about alien in the sense
of belonging to a different tree
altogether that's what we're looking for
life 2.0 and one place we can look is
right here on our home planet no planet
is more earth-like the mouth itself so
if life really does pop up readily
enough light conditions surely it should
have arisen many times over right here
on earth how do we know didn't does
anybody looked remarkably enough until a
few years ago nobody thought to look for
a second sample of life on earth
everybody just naturally assumed that
all life on earth is the same life well
as I've said all life so far studied is
the same life but we haven't studied all
the life there is most life on Earth is
microbes we noticed the big things we
notice the the trees and the elephants
and so on because they're big but the
vast majority of species on earth are
microbes and we've only just scratched
the surface of the microbial realm
probably less than point 1% of microbes
have have been classified let alone
cultured or had their gene sequence and
so really that microbial realm is a
mystery we don't know what those little
bugs are and it's entirely possible that
Inza mingled among the microbes
related to you and me some microbes
which are not on a tree of life at all
they would be genuine the alien life
life 2.0 could be right under our noses
or even a pair noses so I think the most
important way we can advance this quest
for ET is to look right on our home
planet to see if we can find a second
sample of life and I working with people
to do just that
almost saw the effort that is expended
in astrobiology is towards looking for
simple forms of life usually just
microbes so microbes on that would be
our our best hope then there we know
that within the solar system is very
unlikely there'll be anything more
advanced than microbial life but if we
think outside the solar system and then
the distances articles amends then there
could be earth-like planets with more
advanced form of life for example they
could be photosynthesis that's going on
that would leave a signature in the form
of oxygen in the atmospheres of these
planets now it's only the last few years
we've discovered any planets outside the
solar system it's a list of about 450
now and there's a satellite called
Kepler which is going to find a lot more
over the coming year or two and then
we'll have a shopping list of likely
planets may be earth-like planets where
future instruments that would be very
expensive and very technically very
challenging but nevertheless could be
built in decades hence these instruments
could then scrutinize these planets that
we found and see if it can get enough
information about their composition of
their atmospheres to say they may have
life of course again it would be an
indirect signature of life we wouldn't
be seeing the life itself but just its
byproducts say in the form of oxygen so
these are the best hopes but of course I
think from the public's point of view
they're less interested in microbes or
plants they're much more interested in
intelligence aliens and so the search
for intelligent extraterrestrial
intelligent intelligent aliens or
advanced alien civilization something
like that is in the province of the SETI
program and they look set to continue
doing more of the same for the coming
years they've got a better system the
Allen telescope array in Northern
California has been paid for in part by
Paul Allen the co-founder of Microsoft
and this is current down the
construction and when it's finished it
should have 350 dishes which hooked
together will form a telescope with a
very large collecting it as a radio
telescope set again is listening for
radio waves from
T but I think meanwhile we should
broaden the search and start looking for
other things for example even in radio
we should be looking for beacons as well
as so-called narrowband signals the way
that SETI work so far is that they tune
in to the evidence a bit like you tune
into your local radio station that is
that there's a particular they're
looking for a particular frequency a
continuous transmission at some sharp
frequency which is the way we do it
we're sending messages here but there's
another type of message which is in a
words like the message in the bottle
it's a one-way message it's a lighthouse
is a good example of that it it just
sends out a flash for anybody who may or
may not be be out there who's looking in
the same way we can imagine that some
aid in civilization may be long vanish
has made a beacon that's sweeping the
plane of the galaxy and it would just be
something that goes bleep in the night
you'd hear this bleep that's et pinging
us you maybe wait a few months or years
and it would ping us again and if you
hear enough of those pings you would sit
up and pay attention the safety programs
not well geared up for for the pings and
they're trying to diversify their
technique so they can search for such
things but it really needs a more
expensive system a dedicated instruments
radio telescopes to stare at some
particular patch of sky for months or
years on end just so that you see the
repeat of these pings so at the moment
if if a radio telescope picks up a ping
a transient pulse of some sort what can
you do can shrug and say well there were
some strange strange pulse came from
over there there's nothing I can do
about it it's been and it's gone you
can't get somebody else to observe it
because it's all over and there have
been many examples of recorded transient
events of that nature nobody knows what
they are they could have natural
explanations or maybe these really are
beacons we shall have to wait and see